بين روسيا وتركيا ملفات هامه تبحث عن ضبط
ايقاع واحد وزير الخارجيه التركيه
على الاهميه البالغه لاتفاق توريد الحبوب
عبر البحر الاسود وضروره اسراء الدول
الغربيه للمطالب الروسيه قبل استئناف
العمل باتفاق الحبوب
تطالب روسيا بتصدير منتجاتها من الحبوب
والاسمده دون انقطاع وقد اكدنا مجددا
اهميه الاستجابه لهذه الطلبات بفضل جهود
بلادنا اعدت الامم المتحده مجموعه جديده
من المقترحات نعتقد ان هذا هو الاساس
المناسب لاعاده تفعيل المبادره
اعاده تفعيل مبادره البحر الاسود لتوليد
الحبوب متوقفه الان على حصول روسيا على
الضمانات التي تطالب بها موسكو سحبت من
هذا الاتفاق المهم للامدادات الغذائيه في
يوليو تموز الماضي وانتقدت خصوصا عرقله
صادراتها من الحبوب بس بب العقوبات
الغربيه
وتعتمد اوكرانيا الان في تصدير حبوبها على
الطرق البريه وعلى مرفا نهري غير عميق ما
يحد كثيرا من كميات الحبوب المصدره
وتسعى تركيا الى احياء الاتفاق املا في
استخدامه منطلقا لمفاوضات سلام اوسع بين
كييف وموسكو